大家好，我叫戴维·布朗，这是一堂发音课。
你好，欢迎。你怎么样？
你好，谢谢。我很好。您呢？
我非常好。谢谢。你叫什么名字？
我叫洛德斯 (Luòdésī)。洛德斯·兰达。
你好，洛德斯女士。欢迎。我是布朗先生。你来自哪里？
我来自洪都拉斯特古西加尔巴。
好的，特古西加尔巴。太棒了。我的妻子来自特古西加尔巴。
哦，那太好了。
是的，很高兴认识你。
我也很高兴认识您。
我看到您选择了一节关于这些不同 TH 音的课程。可以吗？
是的，没错。
好的，我们有两个可能比较棘手的音。我们有不发声的 TH 音和发声的 TH 音。
两者都涉及到把你的舌头放在牙齿之间。
其中一个，发声的那个有振动，而不发声的那个没有振动。
我们需要知道什么时候使用这个，以及什么时候记住如何使用这些不同的音。
那么我们开始吧。一个问题。你有没有在想说 think 的时候说成 sync，或者想说 three 的时候说成 free？
我想我以前这样做过。
这很常见。甚至一些母语者，例如，有些母语者会说 birth day 时用 F 音代替 TH 音。
稍加练习。你知道舌头应该放在哪里。如果你知道它发出什么音，这些音从哪里来。
这很容易就能纠正。你可以学会听辨和发出这些不同的音。
好的。
这里有一些目标。我希望你读一下这些。
嗯，我希望你们听一下这里的这些目标。所以我们将能够区分这些 TH 音。我们有清摩擦音和浊摩擦音。
我们将描述并演示发出这些不同音的正确口部动作机制。
我将能够准确地在单个词语中以及短语中发出这些音。所以我们将尝试在语境中使用它们。
并且我们将尝试识别与 TH 相关的常见拼写模式。
你基本上需要在每次使用 TH 时注意并自我纠正，然后练习。
所以今天的课是对发音进行一些微调。
你对自己的发音感觉如何？你觉得你需要练习发音吗？
是的，当然。
好的。我认为这堂课即使对我们一些母语者来说也很好。所以如果你感到紧张，不用担心。这完全正常。
并且不要害怕显得傻气。当你用舌头和牙齿发出奇怪的声音时，这堂课会很有趣。
谢谢。
改进这一点可以帮助你的日常对话或工作。顺便问一下，洛德斯，你是做什么工作的？你的职业是什么？
我实际上在政府部门工作。
在一个办公室的法律部门。
而且实际上只有少数几个人会说英语。所以当类似的事情发生时，他们需要我的帮助。
而且我认为如果我知道如何正确发这些词的音，那会非常有用，因为很容易混淆。
好的，当然。所以你今天有充分的理由来练习并改进你的发音。
我们需要理解这两个不同的音，以及清音和浊音意味着什么，因为，嗯，任何时候我们说话，我们都能感觉到振动或者感觉不到。
所以如果你把手放在喉咙前面这里，你能为我这样做吗。
然后开始说话。说点什么。也许一个短语。
你好，我叫诺亚。你好。是的，我确实能感觉到。
所以你看到有些时候它会振动，有些时候它不会振动。
基本上，这些浊音与元音的发声方式有关，我们会在词语的不同部分找到它们。
这些是浊音。而那些我们发出的、在这里不振动的音，是清音。
所以我们在图表中看到两个不同的例子，一个是清音的 thick。
并且没有振动。所以如果你把手放在这里，为我把手放在这里然后说，thick，
thick，你根本不应该感觉到任何振动，对吧？
再说一遍，thick，没有振动。也许对于，是的，但是对于 TH，没有，对吧？
现在，下一个，请你再试一次，甚至舌头也会振动，对吧？
所以如果振动，是的，一直向上，这种振动和声道会继续向前，
我们用这些发出浊音。所以我们用 TH 和这里的元音发出浊音。
所以某些辅音也可能伴随着不同类型的浊音，比如这些浊摩擦音。
所以这是像 think 这样的词中的音，没有振动，对吧？
Thank, then, back, path 和 three.
Thank.
现在，确保你的舌头在牙齿之间。你能为我们读一下这部分吗？
Think, think, think, think, back, three.
好的，很好。所以注意这些音不振动。
所以我们不想混淆这些，比如说 think，这个音听起来更像一个 dip 音。
我们不应该在不该用的时候用浊摩擦音，反之亦然。
所以这需要一些记忆和一些这里的振动。
所以我们在这里练习 TH 音。记住，你不应该感觉到那里的嗡嗡声。
让我们再试一次。我们将尝试，和，那个，对于这个音，你可以在手上感觉到一点气流。
你能说，
我想，呃，结尾有点。
那个，呃，我想，那里的 TH 音不是浊音。
这是一个细微的差别，但对于发音来说很重要。
所以我们可以看到这些之间的一些区别。
基本上，它们唯一的区别。
在这两张图片中，你的舌头都在牙齿之间，呃，舌头在牙齿之间。
但是对于浊摩擦音，你还有那种振动。
好的，所以我想我已经解释清楚了，你也理解了，对吧？
这是现在带有嗡嗡声的词语中的音。
我想我明白了。我知道我必须练习。
所以这些词里有嗡嗡声。那么听我说一遍。
我们有 this。所以你有振动。
This, that, then, mother, breathe, 还有 they, 你试试。
好的，让我们看看。
Breathe, that, then, mother, breath, they.
很好。这个。Breathe, breathe, breathe, breathe.
很好。Breathe.
嗯？所以注意那里的振动应该像一个声音，像嗡嗡声。
Breathe. 很好。
好多了。
我想你害怕发出另一个音。
另一个带有浊音的例子是字母 S。
有时它也会发出声音，与那个清音相对。
所以这是那里唯一的区别。